i really don't know what that means i
don't know what any of these means
okay because i never said thirst trap i
want a thirst trap but i don't know what
that is
[Music]
what's up vr phil mickelson here i've
played golf for a long time and kind of
proven that
uh i'm okay on the golf course and now
i'm working on
developing my social media skills so
how am i doing and how can i get better
you're the quarterback of a football
team playing in the super bowl
a team from new york has just defeated
you and a photo is taken of you sitting
on the field
with your head facing down people begin
to recreate your photo and post to
twitter with different captions
you have officially become a meme
actually knew that one wow phil that's
me
says he wants to thirst trap and post a
photo of his
my cavs on instagram with the caption
felt cute might delete later
hashtag friday feeling what is a thirst
trap well first of all there's nothing
cute
about my calves and second why would i
want to delete it
who knows
[Music]
what is a burner account and which of
the four match participants is most
likely to have a burner
account a burner account is an account
where you can go
onto social media and people won't know
that it's you
and i think we're all pretty likely to
have one of those because
we'd like to have a little bit of
privacy on social media and not have
people know
that it's us but um
kevin durant would be the most likely
it was durant that got caught doing that
right is that right okay cool